[Music]
all right so
so uh where'd you grow up where you from
originally
los angeles
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents
no i did not have a father i had a
mother
how would you describe your childhood
not so different from your average
los angeles middle class
or lower middle class
life
no crazy views nothing like that
yes
there is some abuse
the details are left for
you know
professional help
and so okay and um
what kind of kid were you in high school
i'm sorry what kind of kid were you in
high school
um
just a good guy good kid
you graduated
yes
what'd you do after high school
um i went to college i studied uh
theater
i studied uh
psychology
i studied
biotechnology fire science and uh
i studied emergency medicine
emt certified
that's great
you've had jobs yes of course i've been
working since i was 14 or
so yes
i'm 31 31 years old how did you end up
panhandling on the
freeway exit um homeless
i i overworked i i worked many hours in
delivery and
uh
and uh
rideshare companies
and
i i was exposed to a lot of uh
psychic activity different psychic
activity from different
morals and
religious sensuality
and it really had an effect on my brain
because they're all inflicting you know
you have many different ideology
ideologies and they're all
against each other and you have this
driver delivery guy and he's right in
the middle making some money so it does
have an effect on the psyche very much
so
so yeah and then i lost i lost all my my
stuff
why did you lose your stuff
lucid faringly you know in in in a weird
way you know but
i i would not know how to describe that
but your belongings are basically
everything in your backpack and i'm
sorry your belongings are basically
everything in your backpack and your
and your back yes yes
i lost my car you know i lost
after you lost your employment i guess
everything kind of came apart
yes yes
yeah yeah but it's it's not too bad i'll
tell you what the learning experience is
worth a lot more to me uh since i have
been homeless i learned
so much universal logic that's that's
really good for the human to evolve as a
light being
and so this is the part that i value
worth more than money
and that's all really that's yeah would
you describe yourself as happy at this
point in your life absolutely i'm very
happy uh not only am i conscious of or
but do i have knowledge of
uh a higher being that looks after the
human beings and that creates a home
within itself for the homeless
and your your mom you're still in
contact with
my mother is a narcissistic psychopath
that's very self-centered and uh loves
herself on a deep level of consciousness
uh within a splash within a flavor of
the tree of knowledge of self she loves
her herself
on on a deeper consciousness than than
than your average semester of learning
you would have to take a few years to
learn that type of psychopath within
psychology itself and that is comedy
[Music]
do you have children have your own
no i do not have children no children
you've been married
no i've not been married you ever been
in love
yes i have been in love of course
and um
do you have any friends at this point in
your life i do have friends uh believe
it or not yes
yes
you stay in contact with them they know
you're out here
uh
yeah some of them are homeless some of
them are not i mean you i would consider
you a friend i mean you just popped out
of nowhere
asked me for an interview so hey that's
a friend why not that's right that's
right what uh where do you stay where do
you sleep at night uh i sleep in in
beverly hills uh the streets are cleaner
i kind of like it it's not too bad so
you're not done it's scary i picked you
up in culver city absolutely yeah you're
not far from from beverly hills yes
which what kind of money do you collect
every day doing this ah
first off how many hours will you be out
there on the on the corner well i just i
plan to have a goal just to make my
needs
make my needs met or may
meet the
meet my needs
you know and uh if that's if you're
considering amount of money by begging
on a good day i make fifty dollars
and i usually get some medicine like
some marijuana or some food or clothing
and that's about it really yeah drugs
are not a part of your life no i don't
really do drugs
i mean i
i mean there is that reality that
marijuana is a psychoactive it is a drug
but it's
it doesn't matter that's a whole nother
subject i don't really want to get into
that
it is
what's your biggest regret
um my biggest regret is
not understanding my surrounding
at a young age very well because
understanding gives freedom light gives
freedom
if i had the same light that i
have now when i was
13 or
from the age of 1 on to 25 or so
i would be thinking a lot differently i
would probably be who
i've always wanted to be by now
what goals did you have when you were
younger i'm sorry what did you want to
be when you were younger
uh
an actor
yeah i wanted to be an actor but then i
am a musician
and then there's that whole deciding
what you want to do thing but yeah i am
an actor a musician a songwriter a
singer
uh
what else
the whole creative community just one
hand
what emotions do you go through
living this lifestyle
uh
loneliness that's really the the biggest
emotion
but it's it's a beautiful thing uh this
is this is where you learn
oftentimes we miss a side of
the negative emotion or the we miss a
side of the negative
presentation sometimes a life lesson
presents itself
as negative but then there is that
positive side there's not a positive
tied to every negative i'm sorry there's
always a positive tied to every negative
yes absolutely and so
i mean i've learned words that i've i've
never read before you know uh just
within this
uh
spiritual homeless existence
you know
but anyways but uh what do you worry
about
what stresses you out what are you
worried about what am i worried about
well i i'm kind of um
not
i don't have ultimatums
but
i i do i i do like to sense what
centralized life
in general you know
we grow up having the
uh preordained image or preordained
life
uh the the movie of life the story of
life the boy grew up the boy went to
college the boy got married the boy had
a family
that's just ordained in our mind and
that's not so bad
you know and so i do have that that
ultimatum where i have to know where i
end up in life and i figured it out i'm
not worried about it anymore i've
already figured out where i'm going to
end up rich or poor
and that's one of the biggest lessons
is
to know
where you're going to end up
highlighting rich or poor
that often answers a lot of questions
[Music]
what's been the roughest point of your
life
the most difficult part being exposed to
certain realities a certain
pain
that the human being goes through
not just me but just just the human the
homeless human
you know
or not really there's a lot of people
that go through pain
while they have homes so it's not really
that big of a difference
what is stopping you from
going to the car wash across the street
from where you were and just getting a
job
i have i actually have tried to get jobs
i i do suffer from
uh
hyper
activity
hyper psychic activity of the mind this
is what the this is what the medical
community would consider would call
psychosis or schizophrenia
or
whatever it would what it really is is
hyperactivity hyper psychic activity of
the mind or
hyper or hypo hypo psychic activity
it's it's close enough really you've had
this since what age
uh since i've realized what it is but
i've had it all my life really i've been
suffering from that all my life did you
develop in your 20s
i just i i i what it really is a
psychedelic experiences
that's all it really is even when you
don't know what it's what's going on
i've had psychedelic experiences i as a
young child without any drugs just
because of that state
and it's just amazing
what's your favorite memory in your life
favorite memory um
dolphins in the ocean
swimming in blue water
[Music]
it's nice
what what does your typical day look
like you wake up
i wake up i reach for a cigarette and i
hope i can i hope i have a good day
without going demonic you know without
just having
you know my just without going crazy
really that's yeah without your
psychosis acting up
without getting without coming across
different burning flares of morals again
it goes back to you know
we are human beings and we have a
we have
i mean you get this guy from this
religion and you get this guy from this
religion and they you know they're
walking and they walk right past each
other and their religions conflict right
and even in silence you feel that
burning flare or moral or whatever it is
it's just
it goes deeper than than you think
really if i
the details i would like to give
um
i don't know
are you religious
am i religious no i'm not religious at
all i don't know yeah
so so back to your typical day i met the
i meant the kind of the
the you'll get up in the morning you'll
go down to the street corner a busy
corner and with your sign and you'll
hopefully
get some people donating money
yes well this is just temporary you know
i am also a traveler
uh i the reason a big reason of why i am
uh begging or panhandling
is because i'm a traveler how long have
you been homeless i've been homeless for
about six years
yes and so i just i just need some cash
in my pocket while i'm overseas or in
another state
and it's it's not a bad idea yeah
are you saving money doing this or you
just yeah absolutely yes i'm yes
i am saying do you have a bank account
no i do not have a bank
um but i'm also an artist you know
from a pen every drop the streak of
expression counts and a thought on a
page for a flake in a bosom
dream unity and connection based on
astrological satisfaction created in
childhood sensuality as rays connecting
under the sun's heaven is the age based
on a kingdom come
the quiet stillness of a mind resting in
fullness points to the god of its light
in moral darkness
the heartbeat finds its rates and
circuits patterned with the exchange of
morals
one more time from the father is
brighter than the rays as the sun
and all the moral buttons find their
prince of existence as they evolve in
the light
and all the rays that shine point to the
treasure that shines as children of gold
closing eyes in the sleep of babel's
morality is man's reach for god's view
and seat the blue sky with blends of
light and time is the place to meet for
the conscious eyes
the light connecting stars from into the
corners of the eye shines at the blue
outline and crown points of the god of
gods
the revolving millisecond morality
persuading who shines is at the speed of
the light of lights and the author of
life
the shred of the soul and its agony is
condoles and each iris morality
and receptiveness of the light
people
sufficient is my selfishness
as distance from the light
so what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
it's to be humble and simple and
accepting and forgiving
excellent
that's all thank you so much for sharing
your story absolutely i wish you the
best of luck out there thank you so much
for having me uh
my name is saul mel thank you very much
thank you very much
you